i have committed myself to understanding
what a woman feels like when she is
penetrated i want to fulfill this
commitment but the match stick won't fit
in my penis
too too square
too square how about
never never forget it
my penis i understand
it's too square i underst what
[Music]
three days me and you free drinks they
can be a chill
this is gonna be on right here dawg this
is gonna be my let's get some dams going
up in this [ __ ] right now you got the
number one track in the country right
now roll with me
and that's my jam right there i love
this song i love this song too man
everybody loves this song what hear me
oh
what blow with me roll with me
[Music]
man
girl you know that i got what you need
see don't get greedy give it up sweetly
let me set that body free cause what you
got you got to give it to me what
ever since i was rocking a onesie i know
that you was second to none
growing up and learning abc's and one
two threes hoping you'd learn we
were meant to be even way back then
every little
[Music]
[Music]
much longer now with me bro you belong
bro with me roll with me let the night
i'm falling man
take it right now
[Music]
what the hell don't turn it off just
because you don't know it what we're
going to do when we get to vegas no no
no no no no don't change the subject
about what we're going to do in vegas if
you don't know the words just admit you
don't know the words the words i told
you why would i make up that i know
don't know
that's ridiculous man no i know the word
it seems like you didn't know the word i
know the word hey listen hey listen to
me man what what i know the words that's
right everybody knows okay no no it's
not okay because you obviously don't
believe me hey dude on our friendship
i know the words
to roll with me
okay
i'm sorry
sorry just let it go i'm sorry that was
stupid stupid
turn it back up
yo i love that drag so much i'm sorry i
gotta play it again this is
[Music]
yeah that really hurts
[Music]
you ready homie hells yeah let's take
these
out
hold up
what
we gotta go back home man
why
i pooped my pants
what just now
i just pulled my pants
you got diarrhea hell no man i ain't gay
we gotta go home right now man let me
change my draw some of the dudes be
trying to smoke is right there man how
you want me to smoke somebody when i got
poop in my pants
are you sure you pooped them am i short
am i short yeah
yes that is poop in my pants nasty man
it's natural man for a three-year-old
not for a hardcore gangster see my real
friend though you wouldn't make such a
big deal out of it wouldn't make such a
big deal out of it
okay you a grown ass man who just in his
drawers oh snap
no you didn't
get you
pants again don't judge you need to get
out of my car and go to the hospital
okay i see how it see
i wouldn't do that to you though you
never would have to do that to me
because under no circumstances whatever
my pants
i'm sorry i judged you apology accepted
how do you uh let's listen to some music
you had a playlist that you like all my
music is good man just put it on random
all right
rock it out this is an audio journal of
my experiments on my own human condition
forgot this was on here let's skip it no
no no no no no no no i want to hear your
thoughts on thanks
tasted my own urine today to make sure i
was still human yeah let's just skip
ahead what the [ __ ] is this it's just
some voice memos my experiments are
going well
i'm hours into my day-long commitment to
stare at myself in the mirror nude i'm
beginning to see my reptilian self
i am the lizard i am the lizard
i taste the bug on my tongue
don't touch it
i just don't touch it
i have committed myself to understanding
what a woman feels like when she is
penetrated i want to fulfill this
commitment but the match stick won't fit
in my penis
too square how about
never never forget it
my penis i understand
it's too scary i underst what
[Music]
i'm adrift in an indifferent universe
only keegan tethers me to reality
i'll take a drive with him tomorrow
i wonder if he senses how i feed off of
his life force
different keegan
wasn't that the turn for our polling
station uh
why no young man uh see we we know a
shorter route to europe
to our democratic polling station you
know how us democrats like a shortcut
like government spending to prop up the
economy nothing more we love than those
uh federal programs
you two are democrats aren't you what
of course we are you see the color of
our skin don't you how could we not
blindly vote democratic i mean that
would be ridiculous whatever all i know
is my polling place closed in 15 minutes
why that would be terrible awful i mean
how are you going to elect tax and spend
politicians if you can't vote
it's hard enough to vote with all those
voter id laws
republicans
gosh darn republicans i know i'm just
like girl
you know if there were any republicans
here
oh
i'd be pissed
i'd be royally pissed
in fact i would take their hard-fought
principles and not shh
right off their keisters
we seem to be driving in circles
uh don't worry we're almost there
look
it appears we've hit somebody we should
get out and help him oh
i am pissed
i'm royally pissed
now although it was only this one man's
fault i will be using all of the old tax
dollars to get healthy thanks to the uh
affordable healthcare act i know it
doesn't seem fair but that's supposedly
the law of the land out there that's
what i've heard you don't look that hurt
why you're wearing those same leather
jackets
and those dad jeans disperse
black republican mother
all right you're doing fine sweetie
now uh malia let's just go easy on the
gas here and come to a complete stop
okay so in the future you want to try
not to go through stop signs
okay just remain calm now and uh what
you're going to want to do is pull up
right here next to the curb
this is why we want to stay in the lines
and we want to follow rules
remember this
license and registration
holy
mr president yeah yeah just uh teaching
malia to drive
well you guys ran a stop sign back there
but that's okay you can go oh no no no
no malia's got to learn what it's like
to drive in the real world here well
this is called consequences malia now i
want you to go ahead and treat us like
you would if i weren't the president
not exactly what i had in mind all right
where you headed youngster yeah i'm uh
headed to the cobo building on jefferson
all right yeah cobo hall jefferson
avenue
so uh what what you in detroit for i
gotta do a presentation all right okay
yeah presentation okay you know
where you present
uh
actually it's about how market research
can be interpreted with out-of-the-box
solutions oh all right so you won't get
this all outside the box all right
most people think that uh all customers
are a single demographic oh okay you
trying to get all them demographics up
in here all right all right yeah
online trends are less linear oh okay
online trans
linea
also thinking about doing the
presentation naked
no clothes on oh yeah yeah naked
presentation no clothes on that's good
afterward i might just piss on the floor
in front of everyone oh yeah okay all
right piss him right there up in front
of everybody
all right i'm good then i might just
shoot everybody in the place you know
with the gun i'm hiding in my ass yeah
your gun way up in that ass that's the
way to do it cut my victims faces off
wear them as masks mm-hmm yeah masks go
on the face uh yeah okay
it could be nine shine hail hitler yep
okay hi hello
all right here we are
oh by the way
when you kill those people with your ass
gun
make sure to use a serrated blade to cut
the faces off
i'll feed his aim
[Music]
oh
[Music]